hey let's go bros my name is welcome to
today
buckle up good because we're gonna go
you guessed it because you read the
title don't credit yourself too much
back in ten he's gonna know there's many
website that archives websites and i
thought we're gonna go and check out
youtube.com slash beautify let's go back
in time baby so the earliest from my
channel is from 2011 there's a youtube
used to look like about that you can
have these cool subscribed things we had
eight thousand subscribers back then
damn it's funny eight thousand
subscribers which i actually considered
like i don't want to brag breads but i
was kind of a big deal back then oh yeah
you could add as friend whatever the
[ __ ] that did I mostly play scary games
you're either laughing at me or
screaming with me it smiley face my name
is PewDiePie or at least that's what I'm
called I'm a PC gamer at heart
and I'm here to spread the love also see
wait I kept with that ever since and I'm
still a PC game right hard that's that's
what I do
there used to be this thing where you
get these awards for different things
and I had what's my best award fourth
most viewed this week as a reporter in
Sweden hell yeah let's see what people
said back then no haters did the same
[ __ ] you are a legend your reactions are
hilarious I enjoy hearing you scream
like a girl you deserve a lot more subs
I agree oh [ __ ] look at this I had
t-shirts I used to have beauty it's
obvious that was probably the first
running joke out of my channel because I
didn't edit my videos back then and I
keep kept getting stuck and I wouldn't
edit out the parts where I got stuck and
everyone would just be like oh my god
pity it's so obvious
and now I'm number one most subscribes
reporter hey and I set up this email
website where you could email me because
all that private and messages was
getting too much
number one horror youtuber baby now
we're at 60,000 subscribers I was
getting a little cocky look at that
number one horror youtuber YouTube
changed their their layout and everyone
got so pissed at it I honestly I prefer
this one than than the current one I
think this one was the best one but
simple easy to find all the playlists
and your newest videos now it's just a
[ __ ] mess honestly and it takes away
all the personality oh man look I look
like a little Sunday's would feed if I
couldn't get it bad right back that
either could I so 2012 was really the
year where the channel blew up beginning
of 2012 I had a hundred thousand
subscribers and by the end of it in
December I had 3.4 million that's
[ __ ] crazy 2012 was just insane
before I had you I was studying at
university and I didn't have that much
time to make videos then it became my
job to do it and it gave me so much more
time to do it
I could really put my heart into it and
that really showed results getting
youtube as my job it's been one of the
greatest thing that's ever happened to
me by far and here's where the layout
changed yet again it's [ __ ] insane
how the channel was growing at that
point like nine ten twelve fifteen
[ __ ] crazy eighteen twenty seven
million Jesus Christ myth oh my god it's
just so crazy yes
just hit 1 million it's insane I'm so
happy an amazed
that's cool man this is a lot of button
let's go to today and here we are today
36 million bros Wow these five years I
guess now has just been incredible and I
love every single day I never have a
boring day doing YouTube it's just
incredible thank you to all of you
so much for being subscribed across
years now a lot of people feel kind of
maybe left out because they subscribed
to me when I only did horror games and
they feel like oh he doesn't play horror
games anymore but if I was forced to
play horror games all the time I I
wouldn't be making videos anymore
because that wouldn't be fun for me and
then I'm not gonna force myself to do
something I don't want to do I do
YouTube yes it's my job but I do it
because I love it and it's because it's
fun and and I need to do what I want to
do to keep it that way and I'm just
really that my point is that I'm just
really happy that you bros watch me no
matter what I do you see pass maybe just
the game I play I hope I don't know I'll
have to end it there thank you both so
much for being bros throughout the years
I hope there will be many more to come
and we can do another one in five years
how about that alright first stay
awesome
you